the head of police in the German city of
Stuttgart says he has never seen
anything like it in some 50 years on the
job on Saturday night police lost
control as about 500 young people rioted
looted and attacked officers of the city
centre at least 19 police were injured
24 people were arrested as violence
erupted after police searched the youth
for illegal drugs shattered glass
ransacked shops Stuttgart streets after
Saturday night's chaos hundreds of
people came to this park to party when
the police arrived suspecting a drugs
offence the situation escalated people
threw stones and bottles and attacked
police cars several officers were
injured police called to the scene
described it as completely out of
control
in some lines in full its the police all
in all 19 police officers were injured
last night one of them was hurt so badly
had to be taken off duty his number
could still rise as officers often
report their injuries afterwards videos
circulating on social media shows
several groups turning violent
destroying shop fronts and looting until
the early hours of the morning this
ordinance Kazama invaded and for love
the night 40 stores were attacked shop
windows were smashed and destroyed from
what we know at present nine shops were
looted thus knowing language of the
kindled warden the next day stuttgart
residents reacted to the destruction
we've never seen this in Stuttgart I'm
completely shocked I just can't really
believe it Kagame clogged up the spas I
found out about it through a video I
just saw someone throwing stones at the
shop criminal damage destroying other
people's property that's not OK
police are currently gathering evidence
from the shops destroyed overnight more
than 20 people arrested during the
violence are now being questioned
GWS rebecca Stoudemire is standing by
for us right now in stuttgart good day
to you Rebecca can you give us some more
details about the riders the looters and
how they organized absolutely so what
police are saying is that many of the
suspects many of the people involved in
the clashes are from the city's
so-called party scene I spoke with many
of the people I spoke with several of
the people who actually said that they
were there on Saturday night this does
not appear to be an organized group per
se they said that they were just aggro a
group of lots of friends who were
gathering in separate groups who then
came together out of solidarity when
police went to go search another team
for for drugs now many of these of the
people who were involved they're young
they're in their late teens early 20s
and many of them themselves also said
they didn't understand how how things
got so out of hand and why things
escalated so quickly some of them said
that there have been tensions with
police and that there's been a larger
conversation about relations with police
especially in light of the u.s. protests
against police brutality but some also
cited frustrations over the coronavirus
lockdown saying that that they felt
isolated and that they were frustrated
sort of in general with the situation
and one of the main things that they say
also told me was that alcohol was
definitely a factor in what occurred on
Saturday night and police are saying
that this is not a politically motivated
they do not believe that there was a
political motivation behind what
happened here the water police saying
about any more arrests that might be in
the pipeline
well authorities have launched a massive
investigation into what happened and
they are going to be looking through
through the evidence in the shops that
were damaged and the ones that were
looted they were going there but there
were only so far only 24 arrests and
between 400 to 500 people are believed
to have been involved so these
investigations are going to take some
time and many of the people
who were involved were also wearing
masks and and covering their faces so
police are definitely facing an uphill
battle in in determining exactly who was
involved
Rebecca looking at those runed
businesses behind you today in Stuttgart
a lot of people there are not going to
be returning to work today
what do citizens want to see to keep
this from happening again
not only in Stuttgart but in other
German urban areas well a lot of people
are calling for hard or strict measures
against the people who were involved
something to send a signal that this
type of violence that these types of
clashes are not okay and that they will
not be tolerated
the state and Tyrael Minister of Baden
button bag the state where Stuttgart is
located said that they will be following
they will be pursuing the suspects to
the full extent of the law and that
they're calling for justice they're also
going to be looking more firmly into the
city's so-called party scene and and
doing more patrols putting more police
on the streets and and and inspecting
this scene and making sure that these
gatherings don't get out of hand the way
that they did on Saturday night Rebecca
thanks very much for bringing us
up-to-date from the city center there in
Stuttgart today